hello and welcome the footnotes I'm
recapping the most ravishing ideas from
around wired today we're talking about
the greatest dinosaur rivalry since a
Stegosaurus told a velociraptor that her
nails looked like underwire reported on
the announcement of a new movie about
the bitter feud between real-life
paleontologists off Neil Marsh played by
James Gandolfini and the hilariously
named Edward drinker cope played by
Steve Carell to find named Horace
parents think it's a retelling of the
famed bone Wars of the late 1800s in
which marsh and kope scoured the
American West in search of Dino fossils
sabotaging each other's expeditions and
telling each other that their nails look
like this is all happening at a very
exciting time for science Charles Darwin
had just published on the origin of
species in 1859 and indeed once brought
to Marsh banking him for the evidence
his fossils lent to the theory of
evolution and to invite him to his
birthday party which was going to have a
ton of soda and a pretty sweet bounce
house along with Darwin marsh and kope
were among the last of the so-called
gentleman scientist who funded their own
expeditions and were really good at
opening doors for lady dinosaurs but
these two weren't exactly gentlemen for
three decades they nearly drove each
other to insanity with constant
bickering over dig sites and the right
to name certain species such as the
Edward cope is a jerk adan and the i'd
rather be stuck in an actual march than
spend ten minutes with off Neil Marsha
Soros cope and marsh fought across much
of the 19th century American West which
was one of the best regions in the world
for hunting fossils but not so great if
you were dinosaur playing hide and seek
the dew of success here was due in large
part to the lack of vegetation and the
hilly terrain that at one point had
bones poking out of cliff faces as if to
say I'm uncomfortable dig me out of here
only it be in whatever language
dinosaur's bones
the rivals had actually once been
besties but that all changed when Marsh
visited one of cokes early big sites in
New Jersey and bribed all the workers to
send all the fossils to his lab instead
then he went to the shore to get a tan
and a venereal disease so they went to
war for three decades employing spies
and obstructing digs while taking every
opportunity to publicly badmouth one
another March took particular advantage
of cope mistakenly placed in the head at
the wrong end of a plesiosaur
reconstruction which March for some
reason didn't think to call ass
backwards each man eventually ruined the
others career in the process burning
through their massive fortunes which
means they may have well just
constructed skeletons with middle
fingers turned toward the poor but
thanks to marsh and kope today we know
which and the t-rex's head goes on which
makes Jurassic Park way less terrifying
than it could have been
you